hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin and this week the focus is on US
president Donald Trump he was of course
sworn into office last January and will
shortly complete one year in the White
House after what has been a truly
helter-skelter first 12 months featuring
non-stop running battles with his
critics his enemies and even his allies
now a new book fire and fury by
journalist Michael Wolfe portrays a
president and a White House that are
both it seems out of kilter so our
question this week on quadriga
is Trump's first year beyond all reason
question mark and discuss that question
I'm joined here at the studio by three
excellent observers and analysts
beginning with Matthew carnage Nick the
chief Europe correspondent at Politico
and Matthew argues that it might be
tempting to dismiss Donald Trump as a
clown without a coherent agenda but that
he says would be a mistake also with us
is Cristiano Meyer a very familiar face
from German TVs ard network
she believes crazy or not Trump is
divisive and destructive but worse still
are the people who are letting him get
away with it she says she smiles too
yeah and the warm welcome to to Anna's
our bright opinion editor with Berlin's
Targa Spiegel newspaper and a
contributing writer for The New York
Times anna says US foreign policy under
trump is not beyond reason and it's
probably not really Trump's own foreign
policy interesting yeah look forward to
talking about that but first of all Anna
let's talk about this book fire and fury
from Michael Wolfe about goings-on in
the White House about the president you
as somebody who is a sort of a keen
student of US politics I'm eager to hear
what you have to say about this book
well it's entertaining in a terrible way
as the whole Trump presidency is and I
think that's what struck me most is that
you read it and you want to go on
reading it because it's like a really
entertaining piece of journalism and
then you have to tell yourself well this
may not be the full reality but it's
sort of an important part of it so we
shouldn't laugh
that's what we have to remind ourselves
all the time when it's about talking
about Trump is that we should not laugh
about him too much
this is serious Christiana Maya you two
are you you have an eagle eye on
American politics you were a
correspondent in Washington for four
almost yes yes almost eight years what
do you make of the book yeah is it
journalism it's probably both I think it
confirms our worst fears I mean that the
the actual situation in the White House
is probably as described in the book
maybe it's inaccurate in some parts but
it is as my colleague said entertaining
but in a bad way it's like an accident
you can't look away you know you keep
reading it it's it's really amazing how
adaptable human beings are we thought
when Trump took office but this is
totally impossible and we are shocked
and disgusted and whatever else and now
we think it's in the entertaining very
sad and normal destructive situation not
normal I wouldn't go that far
yeah math you can teach Nick what do you
make of it all I mean what's that what
for you when you read the book as much
as you have read what is the most
worrying revelation from the book I you
know I wouldn't say that there's any one
thing that's particularly worrying I
think that the reading the book is a
almost a guilty pleasure number one
because I think for many of us it
confirms as Christian said our worst
fears although I don't think that they
really needed to be confirmed because
they're confirmed every day on Twitter
and elsewhere so I think it's further
confirmation really of what we already
knew that said I think that there are
serious questions about the veracity of
much of what is in the book and some
people say well even if only twenty
percent of what Michael Wolfe is written
here is true that's still horrendous
which is certainly true when you say
horrendous I've got you know one one
line that left out of me Trump won't
read anything not a one page memo not a
breathe not the brief policy papers
nothing yeah that's probably not true I
think that that he will read oh one
Paige memo you know he this is a person
though who went around boasting that he
got through college without opening a
textbook so you know and it's also worth
remembering that the people who are his
base they're not going to be reading
this book number one and they're only
real sort of perception of the book will
probably be on Fox News where the book
is being you know shredded day in and
day out and you know Michael Wolfe sort
of castigated as this charlatan so I
don't think that in terms of his base
it's going to hurt him very much the
people who read the book they've sold a
million copies already apparently are
the people who already hate Trump and
they're going to hate him even more or
if that's going to be a game changer if
it comes blow to the president standing
no no because I think that they've
already been fairly successful in
discrediting the book because there are
factual errors in it man this is sort of
a classic tactic he gets a lot of small
things wrong he has written the book in
a style that is I think for a journal is
somewhat dangerous because he's trying
to recreate conversations and it's
written you know almost like a thriller
in that or a novel and these are
conversations that he didn't witness
firsthand so that's always always
problematic and there a number of cases
that have been pointed out where there
are actual factual errors and that
undermines the book and that's why I say
it's it is you know it's it's it's it's
fun to read but I think you have to take
everything in it with the grandeur but
am i right in saying that it has
nevertheless got under the president's
skin I would say yes um and I agree it
will probably not end the presidency but
I disagree in one point I think some of
the some of the people of his base will
read it because we have seen a little
change there I mean there are people now
in the social networks you can follow
who say well I voted for him but that is
not exactly what I want it in the end so
I think it will add to the what is the
word discredit ation of the president in
a way but it will not end his presidency
so it will have an influence so in any
case and I know one final comment I mean
I'm I'm interested because we haven't
mentioned it yet I mean the remarkable
fact that we have the US president
coming out and not not saying okay that
book is out there I'm ignoring it
because it's not true it's fake it's
lies from
perspective but coming out and actually
defending his own mental health strange
times we live in yes I mean that was a
very strange moment maybe one of the
strangest moments in this presidency
full of strange moments and it shows how
that we do have a narcissist personality
in the Oval Office and that is very very
sound but that makes the book even more
problematic because in being that
entertaining and showing how his
marriage works and ended great New York
Times story about how he spends his day
drinking Coke Zero and watching the
television these are all facts that blur
the full picture that he's actually a
pretty effective president let's talk
about the pretty effective president
Mathew certainly it is a true and
verifiable of fact that the he's going
to have been he's going to be marking
one year in office very shortly we know
that much what's your verdict do you
agree with the ladies that he's a very
effective president yes definitely and I
think part of the strategy is to put
this picture of complete chaos out there
he's sort of presented the presidency as
this kind of reality show we're now
seeing in response to the book actually
to show that he is a serious person that
he can read and so forth we're seeing
the cabinet meetings being televised in
part in this type of thing but you know
this is one aspect of what's going on
this is sort of the public picture and
then behind the scenes his people are
systematically undoing decades of
regulation in the United States number
one if you look at what's happened at
the Environmental Protection Agency for
example it's it's basically being
dismantled they've allowed for example
drilling on both the Atlantic and the
Pacific coasts we're talking about
millions of hectares of sea that will be
opened potentially to drilling in the
coming years it's things like this that
I think really will have an impact in in
the long term and the other big area is
is the courts where he inherited
more vacancies more judicial vacancies
than any other president I believe in
the history of the country and the
significance of this is that he will get
to nominate now more than a hundred I
think it's a hundred and fifty federal
judges potentially in in in the coming
years and these are people who serve out
life terms which means that long after
Trump has left office you will have
judges there sitting on the federal
bench who will be making really
important decisions and this also
includes the Supreme Court
he's already nominated and had approved
one justice and more likely to follow
given the sort of age dynamic on the
Supreme Court so I think that he already
has been very effective in in this
regard it hasn't gotten as much
attention because of the tweets because
of this whole sideshow do it's a
smokescreen or wall I mean I would just
say one more word on that I do think
that he's very vain and I think this is
the problem and that you know he has to
respond to everything but I think that
there are people in the background that
we don't hear so much from that are
really pushing I don't know if it's his
agenda but they're pushing a very
conservative Republican agenda behind
the scenes and it's having make the
whole text I wasn't going to mention or
add the text reform to because I mean
that something is going to have a very
long - yes it's going to have a very
long term effect and it's going to if it
stays in place it's going to affect the
middle classes in ways that make those
problems worse and the socio-economic
problems that have brought Trump into
office so I think there are long term
effects that we can't ignore we talk
about coherent incoherent is that such a
thing as trumpism
there might be but the Inka inerrancy is
also that for example the Republicans
never wanted a huge deficit now Trump
comes along with his tax reform and the
deficit is going to balloon out of
control ultra Keynesian style deficit
sounding so it's totally inconsistent
and at the same time the Republican
agenda is going to be pushed through as
you said on on practically every level
no matter what and I think to say
something critical about ourselves the
press I mean all this distress
tweeting and and sort of saying crazy
stuff you know all that has really
distracted us completely from what is
happening under the radar and all these
things like for example the national
parks you know he's going to really hurt
the country by doing these things and
people have not really realized what is
happening because everybody's going on
about how crazy is all the time and that
makes him a lot less crazy than people
think and none of you have mentioned so
far or at least I think it's true to say
that the what the Washington Post says
is Trump's strongest selling point the
economy yeah yeah well yeah the economy
is doing well it was doing well before
and of course Trump will take credit for
everything he takes credit for you know
every time the the Dow Jones breaks a
new record he sends out you know a tweet
advertising that the economy is doing
well and I think it will have to
continue to do well for him to be
re-elected because people run out of
reasons to vote for him and I think that
in a couple years time when he faces
reelection he's going to really need to
show number one a strong economy and a
lot of progress on these other things
that that he promised including the wall
and a lot of the symbolic things and he
has made progress there too though I
mean if we haven't talked about
Jerusalem and and and and certain other
promises that he made and and these
again the things that matter to his base
even for people who don't like him and I
think depending on what the choice is a
lot of people will hold their nose and
say I really don't like him I don't
think he's a good person even but he's
better than the alternative and he's
doing a lot of what I want and this is
especially true for the Christian base
the conservative Christian base for whom
these judges because of the decisions
they make on issues like abortion and a
lot of other social matters gay marriage
and so forth that's extremely important
to them okay what about Donald Trump the
man we've had some first impressions on
his record we haven't talked enough
about foreign policy Matthew has begun
to mention it let's get some impressions
first of all of what's been going on in
the foreign policy field and then we'll
continue the conversation
Trump's foreign policy is driven by
uncompromising egotism America and Trump
first is his motto he wants to build a
2000 mile-long wall along the border
with Mexico and withdraw from
international trade agreements his plans
to totally and completely stop Muslims
from entering the u.s. have also caused
outrage a complete immigration ban has
been prevented in the courts Trump
started a war of words with North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un and he even seems
to consider nuclear war to be a viable
strategic option and with his unilateral
decision to recognize Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel Trump broke with
diplomatic conventions stirring up anger
in the Arab world and beyond
both his allies and opponents are
baffled by his foreign policy decisions
how dangerous is this president
okay crystianna might take up that
question how dangerous I mean is is
Donald Trump a dangerous president and
who needs to be on the lookout I don't
have an answer to that because no one
knows I mean it's definitely an erratic
person and we we don't really know if he
has a plan and what that plan could
possibly be I mean even his Secretary of
State is more or less unknown person
when it comes to that and we know that
he dismantled a lot of his his whole
staff and that we don't even have an
ambassador in Germany and one year after
Trump took office I mean it's weird and
it's inconsistent and nobody knows what
comes next at least I don't mm-hmm is he
a foreign policy bully Matthew well
clearly I think we've seen that in the
kind of threats that he's made towards
North Korea towards Mexico China you
name it I mean this is just his his
style and some people would argue well
it has been affected in certain
instances well he he would himself argue
about there's been something of a thaw
in the last week or so the last several
days in relations between North and
South Korea Trump says it's because I
threw my weight around because I was
uncompromising well there's my bullied
there might be something to that if
that's really in the interest of the
United States as another is another
question because it appears that North
Korea is really trying to kind of create
a a wedge between Seoul and Washington
here by cozying up to the South Koreans
we'll see we'll see if that works but
you know at the end of the day it's been
very disruptive and this is something
that he wanted to achieve this type of
disruption has been very disruptive in
particular I would argue to the
transatlantic relationship with his
criticism of NATO and even though he
hasn't really followed through on many
of the threats that he's made it has
caused many people in Europe to question
the United States commitment to Europe
to the NATO alliance and it's it's very
problematic I would say for people in
Europe especially in Western Europe who
support the transatlantic relationship
and want its to continue because you
have a lot of which is most people in
jobs maybe most people but you have
mainstream people also in Germany and in
SPD in the Social Democratic Party for
example saying you know we really need
to rethink this this this whole
relationship and look at our options and
it's Pro to put wind in the sails I
would say to people who might have been
a little bit skeptical of the
relationship with America to begin with
oh no this is one of your special fields
well first I'd like to say that as much
as I agree that he's erratic in the
foreign policy area too we do see
continuities and we do see a lot of
coherence and the ideology behind us is
very coherent and it has been put out
and very early in the presidency by
Herbert mat McMaster and Gary Cohn in
op-ed for The Washington Post saying
that which is portraying the world as an
arena of competing actors and they have
been going on with that or they have
been looking at the world like that ever
since and it also shows in the national
security strategy that was just released
in the end of last year and this is how
he looks at Europe - and this is why
there we also see some continuities he's
for example when when it comes to
Eastern Europe he's been very supportive
towards Eastern Europe against Russia
and he has led some of the policies
we've seen with the previous
administrations in place reinforcing
troops sending troops to to Poland and
the whole energy policy were Europe or
US economic interests in selling gas are
come together without your political
interests and this is all very coherent
and like like a block we don't like it
Germany doesn't like it it doesn't like
that sort of hyper-realistic
policies based on national interests but
that's what it is and but I wonder is it
his policy or is it the policy of
coherence of the generals who are
actually I'm their entry point and I was
making yes but as long as they get him
to to hold speeches that I in line with
this policy and they get him to do that
most of the time I think
can still say that it's a pretty
coherent thing we're looking at yeah but
I think they I mean you know that they
say they have to babysit him basically
and make sure that he doesn't any do
anything really super stupid so I wonder
is it a trump coherency or is it
actually the sort of the knowledge of
people who have been around for a long
time in foreign policy and who know how
the game is played and even though they
they they might more or less listen to
him a little bit in what he wants but at
the same time they pretty much do what
has always been done with maybe a little
shift towards Eastern Europe yes but all
in all I would say if it was his policy
it would be coherent at all I think it's
it's just they just keep it from from
totally ballooning out of control what
about Germany that what about Germany's
transatlantic policy I mean you know
Angela Merkel saying the times and we
can fully rely on others are in some
measure overs clearly referring to the
u.s. sigma Gabrielle the foreign
minister relations between the US and
Europe won't be the same anymore
even when Donald Trump leaves the White
House that signals a watershed moment in
transatlantic relations it might
actually I think relations will be
better once he's gone and he will be
gone eventually at the same time I think
that also has to do with the European
feeling of trying to become stronger as
Europe and to be more independent of the
influence of the Americans and the
United States so I think it's a double
strategy also you can see that obviously
we are not them the main partners
anymore but at the same time it gives us
the chance to to sort of look around say
who are we you know who do we want to be
where do we go and what is our aim do we
want to be Europeans you want the
Germans in a special relationship do you
want to be just part of a big scheme of
Western values whatever you know so it's
a redefinition of the own situation and
the European situation talking about
Europe we need to talk a little bit
about what if anything trumpism as we
have called it has to do with the
increasingly influential populist
parties here in Europe certainly many
populist leaders and voters around
Europe see Donald Trump as an
inspiration
Britten's departure from the european
union indicates a historic turning point
one reason so many in britain voted to
leave the EU was a fear of further
immigration
in Austria a right-wing nationalist
government has formed as in both Hungary
and Poland all three share a mistrust of
what they call brussels bureaucracy a
fear of islam and a desire for
isolationism
right-wing populists SAR now driving the
political agendas in many European
countries in Germany two politicians are
talking publicly about a conservative
revolution with an emphasis on homeland
family and Christian values as Donald
Trump the leading figure of this new
shift towards the right America first
yeah Matthew what is the overlap then
between donald trump and trumpism and
far-right populism in europe I think the
overlap is that many of the same forces
that drove Trump into office are also
present in Europe and have been present
for some time
there's backlash against globalization
for example this worry about migration
the refugee crisis and so forth I would
be careful though in assuming that Trump
has had an effect on European politics
directly in the immediate aftermath and
fact of his election we had several
elections in Europe where the populous
didn't win or didn't perform as well as
many had feared in Austria and the
Netherlands and in France of course
where am i coming one against the the
foulness you know so you know III don't
think that there's a direct correlation
there that said this is a phenomenon
throughout the Western world if you will
this this populism and it's not going to
end anytime soon it's it's very virulent
at the moment in Europe in Poland in
Hungary in Austria as we've recently
seen and although you know the populace
didn't win many of these elections they
overall have done pretty well in Europe
over over the past year so I I think
that this is something that the
Europeans are also going to have to
continue to deal with and obviously last
word on this Germany with with the
alternative for Germany now in in in the
parliament is another reminder that this
is a problem that remains I know what is
the alternative for Germany got to do
with with with trumpism I have Saudi
agree with Matthew I think it's parallel
developments that we see with with the
same that came up for the same reason
but there's no or very little direct
influence okay one thing you've written
about because we're only out of time a
little bit but you've written about the
zeitgeist we're so we're marking 50
years of 1968 a time of freedom and
democracy student protests and
what-have-you but there are a lot of
people in Europe there are a lot of
people in the United States who are
saying it was decadent it was
problematic it was it was dangerous
because he bled to the left-wing
terrorism that site-geist what's the
what's the connection between the US and
Germany they're both countries we see of
frustration with what liberalism or post
modern liberalism led to and people feel
like structures that of values are
breaking down and there is nothing to
replace them and they are looking for
new ideologies that give them
orientation in their lives and I think
this is part of where these populist
movements find the force to grow but let
me say I mean in Germany it's 10 maybe
14 percent so the people who are really
frustrated other people are really
frustrated that doesn't mean it's a
complete change of game and I think also
as an effect people have tried to
reassure their own values which is a
positive thing to happen you know and so
I think looking at it in a more positive
way that's a good thing the bad thing or
the influence of Trump the Washington
Post wrote Trump lied 1,950 times so far
and nobody has really contra or very few
people have contradicted him in the New
York Times's right so if that is the new
we you know then we have a problem okay
thank you very much all three of you
fascinating stuff we're gonna have to
leave it there though we've been talking
about Trump's first year beyond all
reason was the question you make up your
reminder hope we given you plenty of
food for thought if you've enjoyed the
show as much as I have come back next
week until then bye-bye choose
you